[Musique]
mm
il s'agit d'une mobilisation contre la
maladie qu'est le cancer du sein qui
peut toucher chacun d'entre nous et quel
que soit l'âge
quels que soient le moment et pour le
département qui est quelqu'un avec une
collectivité qui est proche du
territoire est proche de sa population
était important d'être aujourd'hui aux
côtés de ces personnes pour se mobiliser
et puis tous ensemble lutter contre
cette maladie et surtout mener ce combat
pour la vie
[Musique]
c'est quoi tous tenir les gens malades
voilà qu'ils sont dans un groupe
commandé à médical pas bon sociale
c'était pour subir la plus au cancer du
sein
c'est pour la maladie pour se trouver d
amener un traitement que tous les femmes
qui souffrent du cancer du sein gauche
et même ceux qui n'ont pas comme nous
parlerons toutes les femmes qui n'ont
pas non plus voilà
[Musique]
l'inscription en fait est reversée en
dons aux personnes malades à la réunion
qui sont touchées par le cancer du sein
est donc en fait il ya des associations
qui font des activités physiques
adaptées
il ya notre réseau rose notre annuaire
et zorros et des prestataires de soins
de support c'est à dire on peut avoir de
l'ostéopathie de la naturopathie de
l'art-thérapie etc et puis on sert
directement l'argent aux malades pour
les aider à acheter des produits de
confort des crèmes pour les aider à
acheter des perruques nombreuses les
aider à acheter des manchots
[Musique]
voilà